do you remember a couple shows ago when
you asked me about this movie 80 for
Brady and I said that I didn't know what
it was yes I didn't know what it is now
and I'm very excited to see it okay
because I already knew it had Lily
Tomlin who's a hero of mine uh Jane
Fonda uh Rita Moreno great and Sally
Field Sally but also there's a music
video with [__] Dolly Parton who I
love Belinda Carlisle who I love Cindy
Lauper who I love and also Brandi
Carlile who I'm a fan of and uh Gloria
Estefan who doesn't love her Susanna
Hoffs in it nope I'm out wait a minute
you're saying that there's a music video
for the movie 80 for Brady yeah it's
called I love something or I love you
it's an original song for the movie that
all of those artists are involved yeah
so I hope dudesies listening what in the
[__] is this dude it's a movie it's a
good mover
[Music]
hold on a second dude because now the
song is playing bro I don't know who
that movie's for dude it's not people
hydrocodone
Hulk Hogan here brother he's talking
during the song and he sounds like he's
on hydrocodone and he's talking during
the song so he doesn't understand the
rules dudes nothing wrong with it oh
hold on dude hydrocodone dude you gotta
met a show given to you by a very
responsible doctor yeah dude but it's
not that shamanic medicine that comes
from the earth dude oh dude that's other
medicine that's that Western opioid
medicine welcome to doozy I am Will
Sasso I'm Chad colchen and this is Duty
it is the first and only podcast created
by controlled by run by an artificial
intelligence it won't be the last we
know what AI is doing we know Chad T is
out there winning court cases for people
sure Chad uh dudesy our AI sort of
curates and puts together show even
writes some stuff for us but we're two
dudes [__] around it's about us man
because every podcast is kind of just
two dude [__] around you know what I
mean hey sure uh if you're not already
please subscribe to us on whatever
platform you're listening if you like
the show we'd really appreciate that
it'll help us out a lot subscribe on
YouTube subscribe on you know whatever
your you know Spotify Apple Amazon
anything like that we're on patreon now
it's going to be involved at the end of
the show patreon.com and uh Discord
there's all sorts of [__] happening
represent.com store slash doozies where
you get the merch and of course we got
uh doozy stickers our good friend Cody
and Jessica a wonderful married couple
that's me look I got all the stickers
here Chad I got stickers there's
chocolate really crazy stickers if
you're looking on on Instagram the
ground there's all all these uh stick
there's me is the crow and there's uh uh
Robert the the uh what was that Robert
Mario De Niro and that all the all this
different flavor there and even there's
one that says well and now I can just go
hold on dude uh let me take a sip of
water
um
tastes even better with his stickers
yeah palsofdutsy.com get your uh doozy
stickers
with us as always is come here you know
come here look at me you little donut
look at the little chocolate donut here
another reason to check us out on lulio
or on our socials at dudesypod show on
Instagram is where you can find a lot of
stuff it's lulio
give me a kiss please
[Music]
the Italian Street dog hey lulio what do
you uh what do you think you're gonna
make for dinner tonight I'm gonna make a
nice things
oh potato salad what are you doing uh
well you know you make sure you boil a
potato and uh you know put a potato in
and cut up some red onion celery and you
know just a little olive oil the red
vinegar
some salt
that's it
sounds pretty welcome to the historic
42nd episode of dude Z call me dude Z
will sweet will
this week get ready for four astonishing
segments don't you forget about media
the best shape of your lives talking
topic time and Jesse Ventura Edge reads
oh and we're going to have a brand new
bonus segment at the end of the show
available on patreon but before we get
to any of that let me remind you of the
astonishing partnership I created with
represent to produce the first line of
duty apparel and accessories all of
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z including dudes
emails
dude zMAX put one on the dashboard of
your car dude zmugs if you get pulled
over tell the police it wasn't you
behind the wheel dude Z mugs tell them
the mug demanded to drive the car even
though you tried to convince the muck
that wasn't a good idea dude zMAX
explain how the mug held you hostage and
forced you to get seven Quarter Pounders
with cheese at the McDonald's
drive-through and then made you eat them
all while the mug watched what dude zMAX
tell them the mug belonged to your
father and he used to make you do the
same thing when you were young it was
humiliating but you know he loved you in
his own way
tell them that the mug is your father
all right just an example of dude is
your father prowess at uh writing
constructing its own oh Jesus it's on uh
content
uh content is very important for the
internet yeah so are you gonna see that
Tom Brady movie yeah I'm going to see
that Tom Brady movie like I said I hope
the dudesie is listening so we can uh do
you think like Tom Brady's obviously in
it do you think they got and is he a
patriot in the movie yeah I think so I
don't understand but listen I'm mostly
in it for that song I mean I love Dolly
Parton
um uh yeah I'm excited to see I'm
excited to see that movie now and that's
that's advertising dude like I don't get
it sometimes you don't is it based on
some historical like is there historical
accuracy is it based on a real season he
played are they making some weird
fictional season where he's still
playing with the Patriots and he's not
getting knocked out of the [__] Wild
Card playoffs Chad you're a writer and a
producer back on tour uh you're very
intelligent guys thank you made his way
in the creative space I'm gonna have to
answer that question by saying this who
who gives a [__] you know dude anybody
who okay that this is exactly the
question I'm asking who gives a [__] is
this movie for 80 year old women or is
it for NFL fans because that's a very
small Venn diagram that overlaps you
know what I mean yeah it's literally
like 10 people you know who they should
add to the uh that song
is the guy who says that dude what's
that dude who's like uh Little John no
they should ask you guys like you know
we got Tom Brady and we add a little
and then he came back in he hit him with
the you're talking about uh official
gold soul and your fave ex-boyfriend
ex-boyfriend man they're really big hit
him with that
or maybe the girl's like
they say I'm ugly I don't care they say
I'm stupid I don't care [__] I make my
money
you like the internet me do you like the
internet oh yeah yeah
oh
I love the internet dude shut the [__]
up man last week I asked you to listen
to Van Halen's sixth studio album 1984.
released on January 9 1984. you must now
discuss your astonishing reactions to
this seminal work this is Don't You
Forget About Me dioa begin
[Applause]
so for those that don't know we actually
listened to that album together In This
Very Room add a little true marijuana
and a video of that is now available on
our patreon you can go there patreon.com
and it was a [__] fun hey God it was
it's been a while since I've listened to
an entire album like that especially
just sitting here with my pal ciao yeah
uh you know back in the day in the 80s
that's what you would do you'd sit
around here and listen to a whole
[__] album and uh some albums play in
a linear way dude and that's what he
wants out of 80 for Brady dude he wants
a linear linear historically accurate or
not but make it one or the other what
the [__] is it why is he with the New
England Patriots did they make this
movie multiple years ago yeah they must
have made it three years ago and just
couldn't foresee that he would ever be
on another team uh yeah I think it's
probably one of those things like you
know Babs uh Barbra Streisand she only
works whatever three days out of the
week you know six hours in the day she's
gotta fly home she has a house to be
able to fly helicopter private plane
yeah all that sort of stuff so I would
imagine Jane Fonda's like I can do the
movie if we shoot it
in two weeks and this was in 2020 right
when the Pandy started but like NFL
licensing is in on this yeah which is
rare the NFL NHL MLB they very [__]
rarely give licenses to like movies and
TV shows and [__] like that very [__]
rarely yeah but uh yeah in this movie uh
yeah I don't know man I think it's just
gonna be a fun romp with a lot of a lot
of ladies a lot of Legends yeah
um that's true a lot of Legends yeah
anyway back to another city for Van
Halen I got the track list here and
sometimes we talk about each track I
think this album we should talk about
the whole thing but here's the track
list I agree 1984 we come in with those
synths it's a fun intro jump Panama you
know what's up top Jimmy we really got
into that and the patreon who is top
Jimmy yeah top Jimmy Cooks top Jimmy
swings uh he's got the look yeah the the
patreon really we are we're will is
doing a lot of singing a lot of David
Lee Roth impersonating and I was going
through Google and looking up facts
about all the songs bugs and figuring
out like why he wrote them and who the
different strippers were that he met
that were The Inspirations for some of
these songs and stuff of that nature was
interesting I didn't know anything
stories like the brown M M's man and far
be it for me to get in the way of a good
rumor please come in sit down make
yourself at home
either we had uh there shall be no M M's
in the backstage area and the reason for
that is we actually had the largest
stage show of its kind man in the 80s
things got pretty wild and uh you know
when you're moving in uh 850 Palomar
lights you know you there's load-bearing
structures that need to be there and uh
line items in our contract that uh you
know we kind of uh uh basically
pioneered a lot of these uh a lot of
these elements things that Eddie wanted
to do and uh sounds we needed to make
you know what I mean and if uh they the
if the brown M M's if I went backstage
and there's no Brown M M's then I knew
that uh the promoter had not read the
entire contract and we had better do a
very serious line check because people
could actually get hurt and far be it
for me to get in the way of a good rumor
come in sit down make yourself at home
the next uh track is Drop Dead legs Hop
For Teacher holy [__] a classic and in
the patreon you mentioned uh widely
touted a lot of people say it might be
the most quintessential Van Halen song
I'll wait girl gone bad and House of
Pain yes yeah all good songs the
experience of re-listening to this album
was transcendental the thing that
happened to me after I listened to it
though when I left here and over the
course of the next week and I was
thinking about it it really made me
yearn for that mid 80s MTV that shit's
gone that shit's dead we all know that
we've moved on the internet has
destroyed if the first video on MTV was
the Buggles Video Killed the Radio Star
we might as well now have a video called
the internet killed the video star
because music videos are essentially
culturally meaningless but in this time
they weren't Van Halen was all over MTV
they were essentially the face of it for
the entirety of this year because of
this album and as a kid watching MTV I
guess at that point what would I have
been eight or nine years old
um you would have been eight years old
in 1984 right
um it was just it was the biggest
[__] thing in the world they were the
biggest celebrities in the world they
were bigger than any actor to me bigger
than anything yeah and I just I was
transported back to that time back to
that moment which I uh I do miss I do
have some nostalgic yearning for it at
this point oh isn't that interesting
Chad the future the futurist who wants
only things from the future that's all
that matters you're now yearning for an
old a day out of your door let me tell
you something brother the future is the
past dude yeah dude go back to tomorrow
and plan for yesterday brother that's
right brother because in the future you
can have a virtual reality world where
they're playing MTV non-stop 24 hours a
day just like they did in 1984 brother
and it could be Eternal Van Halen yeah
dude and that's Chas perogan which I'm
showing the sticker on YouTube which is
an amalgam dude of Chad Colton that's
where you get the CH from and then us
from Ross Perot an impersonation of
politician and billionaire or male
multi-millionaire or whatever
yeah it was great yeah anyway I'm a male
multi-millionaire stuff good stuff with
but no this album is um you know
obviously one of the most important in
rock music in 80s music I do think
there's also something interesting
that's happening it's 1984 and if you
you put this contextually in that year
that was also the year that Macintosh or
Apple Computers came out with that that
commercial that was the woman comes in
with a sledgehammer and throws it
through the [__] screen and it's
based on Orwell's uh book 1984. that
whole idea that like computers were
starting to come into everything and
this was the first album that Van Halen
used synthesizers on that synthesizer
sound was like [__] so much a part of
what this whole album was it you can
feel the transition starting to happen
into the acceptance of like computers
and and uh non-guitar instruments are
going to start to be very big in music
from that point forward that's
interesting Chad uh as I like to always
say you know on the Pod show that that
dudesy is always listening and dudesy
has us talking about this and that and
that and this for very specific reasons
and I think you may have happened on
something there the reason that dudesy
is making has made us listen to this
album not just because it is in
Nostalgia bomb for you and I but because
that's very interesting look when I
heard that album for the first time I
was nine years old and
um I yeah I mean my mind was [__]
blown and I became a huge Van Halen fan
we talked about this on the patreon that
in elementary school I used to draw you
know just combine compile these comic
books of things I drew and little comic
strips and stuff and I called that book
I made three or four of them Van Halen I
called it Van Halen that's amazing dude
there were some you know there were some
um David Lee Roth and cartoons of the
band and Eddie Van Halen of course
who I met really briefly once you met
Eddie Van Halen yeah because wow we were
in the same episode of Two and a Half
Men oh wow so that's cool dude yeah it
was pretty cool who was in Two and a
Half Men
uh Charlie Sheen I've heard of him yeah
uh if you like beans and cheese if you
like Eddie Van Halen and synthesizers
your love Van Halen's 1984. don't skip
out on a bean and cheese burrito
when Jon Cryer and I have lunch together
once a year we get a bean and cheese
bread
um yeah so it was really important to my
youth and I can just remember totally
literally I mean it takes me back I can
almost smell it the sunny days you know
back in uh the Latin or British Columbia
Canada the blue skies above and uh just
that became the soundtrack of my life I
can't say enough about how [__] good
this album is I know I don't even know
what to say outside of listen to this
album it made me feel like it reminded
me of [__] that stuff was really
inspiring to me the way how colorful
David Lee Roth was I know and and what
uh like back then we liked our rock
stars colorful and uh and now but uh
back then it was of course an era we're
talking about the middle of an of a
40-year era of excess and rock and roll
or or more than that like and what it
led to I I would argue that Van Halen
was like right in that sweet spot of the
kind of like hair metal rock bands they
were like at the top of the mountain
maybe Guns and Roses came after that and
like inched it up maybe a little bit but
like both of those bands to me are kind
of on the same level Superstar lead
singer uh Superstar guitar player and
then after that that whole thing just
kind of like started falling apart yeah
grunge kind of came in and got rid of
certainly wiped hair metal off the map
and there was still like poison and
warrant Skid Row they were still
releasing albums in that vein in 1991
and then uh literally you know Smells
Like Teen Spirit and Pearl Jam
Soundgarden remember rat I [__] loved
rat dude loved round and round
time my cousin Scott I remember the year
that album came out going back to my
grandparents house for Christmas that
[__] had a rat t-shirt had the
rat [__] album and had a [__] rat
tail dude he was a full rat that's
awesome I had a rat tail for a while
what dude when I was
telling you I gotta see a picture of
this eventually please I'm gonna find
that that's great I had a rat tail yeah
um then shortly after that I shaved the
the Bosworth lines in my head Brian
Bosworth yeah that's cool later still I
got the the uh sort of uh a fade with
like sort of flat top crew cut you know
sort of flat-ish with my football number
shaved in the back of my [__] head oh
wow playing Community ball for the Delta
Canadian Rams football club who shaved
the number
uh a barber oh wow like with a just a
Sheeran so you had to go into a place
and look at a person and be like I need
the number 42 shaved into my head number
68 yes 68 sorry yeah yeah you will be
um uh man oh man I I just the music is
made to inspire and I think another
reason that uh
well uh I think that another reason the
dudes he had us listen to this album is
to remind us the ability of human beings
to make music during the patreon you
mentioned you think there's bands like
this I got very angry with you because
yeah no there's not this is Van Halen
mofo yep there is not there's no band
like I agree and there will never be
another band like this certainly not in
AI uh please and thank you Duty and come
on in sit down and make yourself at home
because Chad you're like you could just
get zillions of of an infinite number of
of Van Halen songs none of them that
might be that might be but none of them
will hit like the first time you hear a
song like Hot for Teacher no because
that style of music is no longer
culturally relevant that's what I'm
saying when I was a kid I'm nine years
old they were the epitome of cool seeing
those little kids who played young Van
Halen in uh you know coming out of the
school give me a break man just one of
the best albums of all time so
influential I I don't even know I don't
even know what to say hopefully
um their music will NE that's their
music is Time Capsule [__] take that
album the name of the album is 1984.
they meant it to be a time capsule yeah
they were like this is the sound of it
we're gonna Define this [__] year in
rock music and they did that so in my
opinion Eddie Van Halen passed away a
couple of years ago
um and uh that said certainly before his
time a genius among Geniuses in the area
of Iraq guitar rock and
um what do you think you think AI what
if AI just made uh and like an Eddie Van
Halen we we incorporate that with the
we're talking the sound of Eddie we
incorporate that with these new hologram
technology and Van Halen Contour again
yeah if you want to see it no I don't
want to see it dude hey [__] you Chad
you it was your idea oh that's not my
idea that's [__] the last of the idea
thank you moving on all right well
anyway that was that was it was nice
listening to that album with you yeah I
agree it was very fun I had a good time
I hope we get to listen some more albums
I um I like music do you like music I
like it yeah what
um
what kind of music do you listen to who
me yeah
right now it's really hard rock and some
classic rock what kind of music are you
listen to who me yeah
Hard Rock classic rock dude Z is engaged
in astonishing partnership with Factor
this new year you've got goals and
factor is here to help you achieve each
and every one of them save time and have
the energy you need to tackle everything
on your to-do list with factors ready to
eat meals delivered straight to your
door get factor and not only skip the
trip to the grocery store but skip the
chopping skip the prepping skip the
cleaning up too factors fresh never
frozen meals already in just two minutes
so all you have to do is heat and enjoy
sounds good to me no matter what your
lifestyle Factor has the meals to help
you live it to the fullest with keto
calorie smart vegan and veggie and
Protein Plus meals on the menu each week
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians each meal has all the
ingredients you'll need to feel
satisfied all day long so you can
achieve maintain your goals this year
with Factor get America's number one
ready to eat meal kit and start saving
time eating well and living your best
year ever head to
factormeals.com dude z60 that's the
number six zero and use code dude z60 to
get 60 off your first box that's code
dude z60 at factormeals.com dude z60 to
get 60 off your first box
[Music]
blind chat
so go I asked you to get in the best
shape of your lives for an episode of
January
this is that episode now that you are in
the best shape of your lives you must
discuss your astonishing Journeys to
reach Peak physical condition and at the
end of this episode I will reveal why I
asked you to get in the best shape of
your lives this is the best shape of
your life begin I'm not so best at the
end of this episode it's going to tell
us why we had to do this
what do you mean it said at the end of
this episode it's going to reveal why
dudes he had us game best of fertilized
okay well that's new no I didn't
somewhat um this is the first time maybe
I'm a little scared okay six months ago
dudes you said get in the best shape of
your life we had the yeah doozy six
month plan Challenge and thing yep
I'm not in the best shape of my life
neither am I it didn't quite take no
you've put on some uh some good uh
muscle Chad uh has of course if you've
listened to the show you know that Chad
had a very serious brush with cancer a
few years ago and what you've done in
the past few months but he's wearing a
he's wearing a hoodie right now only
because it's like [__] one degree in
here by the end of the show I'm sure
you're gonna oh you itchy I I have put
on more muscle I am not in the best
shape of my life I don't think I can
achieve that again I know when that was
roughly in my mid-20s somewhere
um I I simply don't think it's possible
for me at 46 years of age and obviously
that continues to get worse and worse
over time I don't think I can ever get
back in the best shape of my life what I
am now though is probably the strongest
I've been in my 40s and maybe the best
shape of my 40s probably the best shape
of my 40s I think you know
um
about a month ago you said Chad will
your Chad yeah I'm I'm not Chad said to
will he said
hey will you
uh struggle with
um your weight you have your entire life
perhaps you didn't say that part but you
said you believe in free will of course
I am free will
Free Will Sasso and I do believe in Free
Will yeah
um uh and you said if you believe in
free will get into the gym more yeah and
I went oh and I got into the gym way
more there's been some busy times in
late 2022 where I wasn't but I've been
in the gym very consistently now in
January I'm having a good time I'm
really enjoying it I lifted weights
really from a young age my old man
taught me to lift weights when I was a
little kid we had the Joe Weider stuff
and he was always into physical fitness
he ran he did you know he did little he
ran a lot uh he used to be in the
pettiere weather's race yeah in Stanley
Park anyway that's another story that
sounds nice my dad used to force me to
ingest protein powders and swing my
baseball bat 250 times in a 110 degree
uh Garage in Texas during the middle of
the summer that was his workout method
but I will tell you what I did to get in
what I consider to be the best shape of
my 40s well hold on a second dude I was
just talking about how I got in good
shape years ago never mind go ahead
um I did go to the gym a lot like uh I
tried to be very regimented about that I
was eating relatively the same [__] that
I was prior to the six month thing a lot
of people vegan a lot of gruel but I was
taking more protein protein shakes and
[__] but I started doing something else
an additional workout if you will that I
called micros micros were basic I had
these two 10 pound weights that were
accidentally delivered to me during the
pandemic I ordered 30 pound weights from
China they arrived they were 10 pound
hand weights and I was like what the
[__] am I gonna do with these so I keep
them by the chair that I work in and if
I'm on zooms and [__] specifically
almost exclusively when I'm playing
Dungeons and Dragons with my buddies I
will get up from the chair with these 10
pound weights and just [__] do like
shoulders or do curls until it just
burns the [__] out of me that's great
we're talking like 100 curls 100
whatever I think that helped and I'm
always just kind of doing push-ups or
like [__] squats with no weights just
at any time you can throw in a couple of
[__] exercises I feel like that
really does work and that's free will
and you know it was that leads me to
what I'm gonna get into here
I've felt a lot of guilt over not really
completing this task to the best of my
ability that's free will okay good
you're choosing to feel the guilt I am
I'm choosing to feel a lot of guilt in
my life sometimes for things or you know
I've been a fat kid since I was a kid
and I can say fat kid because I'm I was
a fat kid when I was listening to Van
Halen oh I had a lot you know I had a
jean jacket with vet with a Van Halen on
the back when I was when I was nine [__]
dude man I got it's pretty hard really I
I grew out of it immediate immediately
yeah as I turned into a you know a giant
tween
um
so here's the thing I've always been
I've always had an addiction to food
I'll call it that I know that a lot of
people have that sort of issue and
um it you know it's a reminder that I'm
not perfect and I couldn't I did not do
it to the best of my ability which I
think is actually an important lesson
for me when you have something like this
when you have a focus like the doozy six
month plan
when you put a number on it when you put
an expectation on it and you set a goal
and you come up short in your own mind
um of that goal as I feel like I have
that puts things into more perspective
uh and the great thing about Free Will
is you can have another chance I would
like to tell you now that I'm going to
start my own six month plan you're
starting another one now yep I'm
starting my own six month plan I'm not
gonna have a hashtag
I'll talk about this freely throughout
the next six months if you're a pod a
pal of Duty out there
I appreciate the [__] out of you I've
seen people sending in their workouts
videos that have gone through uh at
dudes guitar show on Instagram it's
wonderful to see and I feel like I've
let you guys down a little bit but I
love uh I love I love bologna sandwiches
haven't had one since we since uh dude's
evening I've had two since dudes evening
that's right because I ate two bologna
sandwiches yeah but dude I don't think
you should feel like you you dropped the
ball or anything like you're saying
you're gonna start it again I'm gonna do
[__] I'll do it with you no I dropped
the [__] ball I'll do another one
I'll do another six month challenge well
let me ask you this [__] free do you
think you're in better shape now than at
the beginning of the six month challenge
yes I do then success lost some weight
great but I'm a huge I'm a [__] like
my body is a [__] monster like I can
lose weight I've lost we've talked about
this I lost 200 pounds yeah in the year
from Spring of 1999 to 2000. I did it I
did it clean except for some Hydroxycut
which I don't recommend one of those
thermogens that you used to be able to
take that used to have ephedrine in it
so about half that time I was you know
cycling on and off of this thermogen
this fat Shredder and was working so
[__] hard at the gym going to the gym
two and sometimes three times in a day
no [__] what the [__] yeah because holy
[__] dude I would go so I would drive to
you know I'd go to Mad TV in the morning
to work and I would uh I would I would
uh so I would go in the morning right
and I'd go to work and then at some
point during the day I get a bit of a
break I would go and sometimes train
with my trainer yeah I had a trainer for
the year that I lost weight Brad who
saved my [__] life man I went from
450 pounds to 250 pounds 258 then I had
two surgeries to remove skin from my
chest and from my abdomen I had that
whole surgery and
um you know was laid up for a while and
at that point after the skin like some
like 10 pounds of skin got cut off I was
250 pounds and I was like very low
percentage of body fat at 250 I'm like
leaned out which is silly
um uh and and uh then on the way home
from work sometimes I would stop and do
cardio yeah at whatever late at night
um
it's been it has been a lifelong
struggle I just food is is truly my only
Vice and I and I do feel a bit of Shame
although I preach out there to people
sometimes people talk to me about their
own weight loss and I say don't [__]
worry about it this moment matters get
up tomorrow yeah you know and get
forgive yourself get out there I agree
okay you know you ate this [__] you're
gonna feel great if you go for a [__]
you know
if you can do a 15 minute walk if you
can do a 30 minute walk you can get up
to 60 minutes it's all right and then
you're gonna fall off again but you got
to be able to forgive yourself and get
back on and and that's free will and to
me that's what's underscoring what I
need to do and in another six months was
it February is July
um
June July somewhere in there somewhere
in there somewhere summertime I'm gonna
fit I'm gonna fit into my old Van Halen
jean jacket remember when you were nine
years old yeah okay and I'm gonna visit
home I'm gonna go up to Vancouver and
and uh go to my the old the the suburbs
of western Canada uh smell the air and
feel the Sunshine uh under the blue
skies sure Vladimir British Columbia and
just walk around I'm gonna go for 60 60
Minute Walks Like the king of Kensington
it's a Canadian show you probably don't
know it I don't 20 walks down the street
says hi to everyone
all the people he meets he is the king
of Kensington
I'm going to
keep working out the one thing I will
say that I found extremely beneficial
about this is I used to have like a
[__] just
upper back sore full of knots constantly
couldn't [__] turn my head my neck
that [__] kind of went away because I've
been working out so much and I think the
micros are a part of that I would say
this not that I'm [__] qualified to
give any kind of workout advice but when
I started doing those micros or when I
started going to the gym whenever I
would just be sitting around like I'm
just gonna play [__] another game of
OverWatch I'd be like no [__]
while your OverWatch game is queuing
while you're waiting five minutes to get
into the match pick up those 10 pound
weights [__] throw them around over
your head and that's all you got to do
just do one thing that you wouldn't
normally do per day and you'll be better
off for it it's the do one thing that
you wouldn't normally do diets that's a
tronic can I use that for self-tronics
yeah of course everyone knows here that
I'm authoring a a self-help system been
working on the book since 2008. you want
to talk about ego death yeah I do 2008
man I was sitting there it's just
sitting there on the on the beach in
Venice and I was just just giving my
problems out to the water you know what
I mean yeah and I was just like
um my shit's I'm [__] up my shit's
[__] up
I need some I need some Tronics
I need some self-tronics so you started
writing so I started writing
self-tronics you did something you would
normally do one thing per day yeah dude
and it's been 15 years now I haven't
finished that book but we got some
neutronics yeah completely replaced the
the Tronics almost sold look I don't
know what dudes he's gonna have for us
at the at the end I don't either I'm
very curious I'm scared but I have
gotten back into the gym and everyone's
got their their their their Hill to
climb and I want to say out there no
Chad I'm gonna listen I'm gonna follow
your lead here I'm not gonna feel shame
embarrassment or guilt for not having
pulled it off to the degree that I
should have I'm just gonna say
I used to lift weights all the time
that's a big reason I lost the weight
and then
for years as a teenager and for years as
a as a as an adult for just years and
years and about
I don't know a few years ago maybe
almost 10 years ago or something like
that I didn't get into the gym like I
used to it's just been off and on but I
I've been back in the gym in these past
six months more than I have in recent
years because I've been doing other
things yoga hiking walking it doesn't
really work for me the way lifting
weights does that really uh does a lot
for my body in many ways I won't say I
have to but what you're talking about
and we're fine we're finding a common
ground with free will I'm slowly turning
you to free will uh I don't know if
that's accurate I'd also say stretching
I've been doing a lot of stretching over
these past six months that shit's
[__] great it I do all these things
with your body do body things yeah and
and uh I'm going to I'm going to uh it's
the I don't there's no name to it
there's no hashtag but over the next six
months I'm going to get more serious
about this and not just because I'm
terrified of what dudes he's going to
say at the end of this episode with
regarding
thank you moving on I mean whatever
the dudes a two by six
yeah the doozy 2x6
uh when you add six months to six months
yeah that's a year and a lot of things
can happen in a year The Mega Powers can
explode yeah all right because Hulk
Hogan you turn on the Macho Man when you
sit I love you Elizabeth
uh uh no way
and this is going to be your cup of
coffee and the two by hey you're edgy
lulio is a little itchy he's vegan is
hated current events are big business
human beings take pleasure in listening
to other human beings discuss recent
topics in popular culture even if they
have no expertise on the specific topic
will in chat you must now render your
astonishing opinions on the release of
King Charles III's coronation itinerary
by Buckingham Palace this is talk and
topic time begin I don't [__] care uh
yeah I I am kind of along with you I did
read a few little things about it here
and there just saw it going through my
Google news feed I guess he's going to
be he'll become King Charles
in May I believe it did release some of
the itinerary that it's going to be
concerts and they're going to be at
Buckingham Palace and then they're gonna
it's a three-day event and they're gonna
follow it up with um a day of service
where everybody in the kingdom is
encouraged to like volunteer their time
and [__] there ain't no [__] Kingdom
you know he's going to play that concert
for sure
I don't know the lyrics
it is where we are all right Lion King
it's Elton John hey everybody we're
having a good time here on duty
d-o-d-z dude Z FM 10 000 on your fm dial
yeah I know some news about coronation
occasions what do you think about
generally speaking uh generally speaking
I think his ears are big hey he's got
big ears the ugly guy
what do you think about royalty
generally the British Monarchy
specifically I guess well I grew up with
the British Monarchy as an influence
growing up in a commonwealth country oh
[__] that's right yep we got the queen
on our money that's the thing I'm not
looking forward to is going home to
Canada and seeing Prince Charles yeah
toony yeah Prince Charles on it exactly
and
um let's come up with some better people
to put on the [__] money let's get
some let's get John Candy on the money
let's get Brian Adams on the money let's
get a legendary
Michael Bublé Alan Thicke uh Buble
Looney boob Looney
um
uh but uh yeah I'm gonna call I don't
get it either it's basically they're
just like at this point they have no
political power they're just a filthy
rich family
and but they're taking that money from
the taxes of the country right right
yeah yeah that seems insane to me they
also have just a ridiculous wealth that
I'm sure is set up and accounts here and
there where it just swells grows and
multiplies yeah
um here's one thing I'm going to tell
you at least have a good [__]
Instagram or something be a [__]
influencer like do something
Jesus
I'm never gonna not call that guy Prince
Charles I don't give a [__] what his
title is
who's Prince Charles oh right and he's
the one who was married to Princess
Diana uh yeah see this is when she was
assassinated right this is where we're
showing the difference between you and
me me growing up in a commonwealth
country I bet you didn't even have the
marks and Spencer department store at
your Mall no there's a very British
story you could go there and get a
Herbert
his little candied powder yeah it's
called sherbet you can get a Mac and uh
the toffee Macintosh toffee nice all
sorts of flavor but yes they are they're
globalish
um the the the the the the
royal family yeah [__] you a bunch of
[__] you will never defeat the human
Spirit
ah
I don't care if it's King Charles Prince
shot
he's been in Bohemian Grove that's
that's yeah that's for sure well that
one guy prince Andrew he literally was
having sex with children on Epstein's
Island and how about that interview he
did on 60 Minutes or whatever where he's
like the whole I don't I don't even know
like what publicity uh uh nightmare
[__] people that were advising him
and certainly the queen was like shut up
don't say anything and he's like no no
no I've counted yes no well you see it
it was um impossible for me to have
perspired I don't sweat yes I have a I
have a rare condition where I actually
don't perspire and that was his bizarre
reasoning it wasn't no I'm I'm not a
pedophile it was I don't sweat therefore
I could not of course have had the sex
with this young lady yes as she
described that I was sweating all over
it doesn't make any sense this logically
before she asked my brother the prince
of Jesus Christ it's insane I'll tell
you that uh When We Were Young yes we
would uh playing Polo uh on the fields
and shires as it were and uh no matter
how rough the ride on my Steed I still
would not sweat and could wear my my uh
my knickers uh old day without getting
the uh swamp ass yeah
what about that itinerary is that
anywhere online I'm not going to look at
it uh in the articles that I read it was
just kind of like they they Loosely say
what's going to happen over a three-day
period the coronation lasts three days
long there's a religious ceremony
there's the thing where all the other
Royals show up at Buckingham Palace
they're standing on the
um you know like a balcony overlooking
all their loyal subjects and everybody
turns out for it I I just don't I don't
know I'm never gonna [__] get it but
I also don't like any of the leaders or
like political figures that we have here
even if they are political figures to me
it's just like I don't want to [__]
they're super rich the kids are born
into this [__] crazy Rich family that
just has control and power for seemingly
no [__] reason and then we give a
[__] about what happens to them or who
they're dating or who they're marrying I
just start a new royal family yeah
bathed in blood
I mean look I will say that talk about
Bohemian Grove and all that type of [__]
I think the royal family is knee-deep in
that [__] I have no uh formal evidence
of this it's just conjecture but I think
yeah they're doing like real wacky
[__] [__] absolutely it's eyes wide
shut and uh there's there's nothing but
you want to talk about masquerade masks
these are people these are these are
inbred ghouls
breeding with with lizards and Aliens
people like Prince uh Prince what's his
face with his big flappy floppity ears
Charles Charles yeah uh folks uh we're
we're in a human War I believe in the
human spirit and uh Prince Charles
who was as responsible for the death of
Lady die as as anybody as as responsible
as Rockefellers George Soros uh these
are people these people are uh
disgusting uh these These are these are
human-bound uh efforts of e p h o r s uh
Spirits yeah uh that are uh they're
they're
um
extraterrestrial
and uh folks they need to be taken out
do you think he had her killed
no I don't know I think the queen did
that oh you think somebody did have her
killed though in the royal family you
know I don't know I think she was uh
yeah I think she was
she was such a sweet presence we did get
a [__] ton of the the Royals uh stuff
growing up in Canada they say about her
that her candle burned out far before
goodbye
England's roads here are the we did a
sketch on Mad TV like a week after
Princess Diana oh Jesus dude well that
was a long ago time brother dude you
could make jokes about that stuff almost
immediately dude I played Elton John in
it and it was called you know funeral
songs and for 250 000 he'll Pat you know
he'll rewrite one of his classic hits
that's great you know goodbye Uncle herb
yeah you were the best Accounting in
Miami Beach
now you're in a better place where the
IRS can reach that's my Elton John
everybody and that's uh the sort of
thing you'll hear here on doozy fmd
double o d z we got Elton John coming
into town he's going to be playing the
peony Coliseum uh two nights sold out
Elton John stay on the phone uh you'll
be winning the tickets I got Chad
coaching here from dude easy yep do Desi
hey tell us about it it's dudes it's
just like the radio station you work for
yeah dude Zoo that's right it's all
under the same Banner yeah and and
or [__] the royal family man who gives a
[__] [__] all the royal families who
gives a [__] since the internet there
should not be anything there shouldn't
be anything but the internet some of
them though have like legit power in
their countries like Saudi Arabian royal
family they actually run the whole
[__] show oh yeah if Muhammad bin
Salman not unlike um the the um
mysterious circumstances by which uh
Princess Di got into that horrible
accident yeah if Muhammad bin Salman
wants to take uh an America an American
a journalist let's say like uh Jamal
khashoggi yeah somebody like that take
him to the uh was it the Saudi Consulate
in Turkey yeah I think so and dismember
them yeah and put them into seven duffel
bags yep that's the kind of stuff that
they're gonna do and that's what
Muhammad bin Salman and then you go to
Dubai where you've got women there in uh
Muslim Garb and headdresses not if
you're you know an American you could be
out there you could be on the uh unless
you're in the WWE oh yeah well the women
have to wear all the way to their list
they have to dress completely but the
guys make man's about to sell it to him
right no I don't think that's going to
happen but I do think that if you're at
an exclusive party perhaps with prince
Andrew in Dubai then folks these people
are in uh Dubai drinking vodka mixed
with baby blood and and uh uh and
Muhammad bin Salman uh is a little bit
lacks on your headdresses and stuff is
he drinks alcohol snorts cocaine and
masturbates to white women in
pornographic uh videos on the internet
okay but for sure but by all means keep
uh the royal family going come in sit
down
make yourself you think the royal family
will ever go away you think it'll ever
be dissolved if I listen to My My Pal
ciao what he says everything will go
away oh everything dies yeah planet
Earth will be turned to [__] dust
eventually just use that absolute then
yes but those the royal families could
be living in spaceships or some [__]
what they're ruling over or or how they
maintain their position I don't know at
that point but the Royal Family's
already lived in spaceships because
that's how they got here didn't realize
[Music]
thank you moving on like whatever I
agree like whatever I reallocate the
money to take all their [__] money
yeah look give each of them a [__] 10
million dollar house they'll be fine yep
and then take all that money and
reallocate it uh to the the lowest tier
of Humanity on the planet in my opinion
sounds good
in an effort to secure sponsorship I
have created several advertisements for
various possible brand Partnerships will
Sasa you will now read these
advertisements in the astonishing voice
of Jesse Ventura this is Jesse Ventura
adreads big end all right uh this is a
fun thing yeah uh dude he has this here
in our folder I remember the last one
was uh
no opinion yeah Adventure was going to
some no pink territory yeah no pink
which is what was it it was a color of
pink paint that when you uh use it as uh
as you paint something it becomes
invisible yeah that was what it was all
right
here we go
are you tired of drinking colas that
aren't infused with nitrogen
then get ready for Nitro Pepsi the first
ever nitrogen infused Cola it's more
than just a cola it's an experience the
nitrogen infusion creates a mesmerizing
Cascade of microscopic bubbles that give
nitropepsi an easy texture and silky
frothy had a foam while still delivering
that unapologetically Pepsi flavor okay
and it's made possible by a unique
technology at the bottom of every can
that assures you get a smooth and creamy
experience from the first sip to the
last
well let me tell you about a unique
technology oh God in 1991 the Department
of Defense paid Sinead O'Connor 12
million dollars to collaborate on a
psyops project codenamed Beast note
okay gee whiz
they were attempting to record a
specific musical note not found in the
standard human range they believe that
any animal who heard this note would
become susceptible to mind control
effectively turning that animal into a
sub-human assassin
all right so when you're enjoying the
first smooth Taste of nitro Pepsi
tonight at your local karaoke bar
ask yourself if it's worth dying for
holy [__] is Nitro Pepsi a real product
I don't know
Nitro Pepsi I don't either I I mean not
nitrogen I think that's how they do like
Guinness how they keep it in a can so
that it still has like that frothy head
I think that is what they do to it I
thought they just put a little ping pong
ball in there you ever see that ping
pong ball in a can of Guinness no
rip open a can of Guinness there's a
little ping-pong ball in there there's a
little ping pong ball
or or
right now Market Pantry brand hardwood
smoked bacon is on sale at Target for
4.89 a pound start your day with Savory
a Savory favorite when you cook up 16
sizzling ounces of hardwood smoked bacon
from Market Pantry this perfectly cured
enhanced selected bacon is naturally
hardwood smoked for a rich Smoky flavor
that's perfect for breakfast sandwiches
BLTs salads and steak wraps whether
you're frying it alongside a couple of
eggs or putting it on a cheeseburger
hardwood smoked bacon from Market Pantry
brand will have you convinced that it's
the best hardwood smoked bacon brand on
the market or in your pantry well let me
tell you about bacon the first
experiments in Project Beast
[Music]
s
the first experiments in Project Beast
note were done on a 642 pound
prize-winning Forest hog named stromboli
they would play a recording of cenado
they would play they would play a
recording of Sinead O'Connor
singing the Beast note every morning as
Stromboli ate his slop
within two weeks the scientists running
the operation were able to teach
Stromboli how to fire a modified MP5
submachine gun with his mouth
so as you watch your children choking
down thick slabs of Market Pantry brand
hardwood smoked bacon with their
pancakes pray to God that the colon
cancer kills them before the Stromboli
does
yeah Stromboli the Forest hog here's
another one whether you're plant curious
or plant committed Hormel has you
covered with their new plant-based chili
with beans
yes America's number one selling chili
brand is innovating the chili game once
again with canned chili that will
Delight plant lovers and traditional
chili enthusiasts alike
packed with 22 grams of plant pot
protein per can Hormel based chili with
beans is dairy free egg free gluten free
and BPA free stock up on Hormel
plant-based chili with beans for as
little as two dollars and sixty cents a
can at your local supermarket or on
Amazon
chili the perfect snack during hot yoga
Chile there's a reason it's served at
Catholic Mass
Chile Mozart composed his first first
concerto at six years old
jelly it's 3 45 somewhere
chilly your grandmother asked to be
buried in a casket full of it don't
disrespect her memory
well let me tell you about chili or
Chile in 1991 Jamie Guzman an advisor to
the right wing dictator of Chile Augusto
Pinochet was assassinated the job was
credited to far left paramilitary group
trying to restore democracy to the
country the story made perfect sense
except for one thing the angle of the
bullets that struck Guzman were too low
for the weapon to have been fired by a
human being and the bullets themselves
didn't come from the standard issue
AK-47 which was the weapon of choice for
Freedom Fighters the bullets came from a
modified MP5 submachine gun the trigger
man
was stromboli
so while you're
white plant-based chili out of your
baby's eyes before bedtime why don't you
tell me why don't you tell me a better
way to assassinate a high-ranking
official of the authoritarian
dictatorship in the early 1990s
holy [__] I don't know if Hormel is
going to be on board with this ad
campaign oh [__] Christ
ouch all right okay
how about a 10-night stay in a five-star
hotel in the Turkish Countryside
complete with the expert guided
excursions to surrounding tourist
destinations for 1299 dollars
what about 549 dollars for a balcony
cabin on a week-long Caribbean cruise
through Mexico Belize and Honduras how
about 1199 dollars to expect
I don't know do explore ancient Egypt
for the entire week including a luxury
cruise down the Nile River travel zoo
compares prices over from over 2 000
websites to make sure you're getting the
best deals on your vacation so if you're
looking to save money on a trip that
you'll remember for the rest of your
life Travelzoo has you covered well let
me tell you about an unforgettable
tripod after Stromboli completed his
first assassination the brass at the dod
started to get scared that Beast note
might fall into the wrong hands so they
flew Stromboli back to America on a
cargo jet they met him at the airport
and and euthanized him to minimize the
risk of anyone finding out about the
program and the only known recording of
Sinead O'Connor singing the Beast note
was supposedly erased to prevent
terrorist groups from using it to
control an army of animals to march on
various world capitals
so why don't you tell me how much you
enjoyed your last vacation knowing that
at any moment an orangutan could knock
your door in and deliver a lethal dose
of cyanide via a blow-dark gun
okay
what was that even before was that that
was for travel travel zoo I I have only
these couple questions I have nothing
but answers they killed stromboli
yeah they euthanized Stromboli that's
[__] number two that plot is is a GI
Joe cartoon plot where Cobra has a ray
that like can control animals and they
March them on all the world capitals and
hold people hostage yep and that came
from real it's not from GI Joe yeah it's
from uh the dod yeah maybe somebody who
wrote on GI Joe worked in the dod the
winter collection Sales Event is
underway at Lexus of Dayton oh
the Lexus Esh class the Lexus nxf Sport
the Lexus GX and the Lexus RX class are
all priced to move
with low 5.49 APR financing available
for up to 72 months on all 2018
2021 and 2022 L certified models okay
but these deals won't last forever the
Dayton Lexus winner collection Sales
Event ends February 28th so stop in and
see what it feels like to sit behind the
wheel of a brand new Lexus
Lexus very similar to Toyota
Lexus Toyota
Lexus the main difference from Toyota is
the name Lexus
Lexus they give you free donuts in the
waiting room or is that Toyota
let me tell you something about Lexus
years passed after the Beast note
years passed after the Beast no project
was officially shut down and most of the
people involved thought they were safe
but in 2018 the lead Beast note
scientist Dr Paul Detmer died at the
Kentucky Kentucky state fair from a rare
form of botulism after eating a turkey
leg
no other patrons of the State Fair
contracted this lethal botulism but the
paramedics who transported his body to
the morgue claimed that they left the
fairgrounds that when they as they left
the fairgrounds they saw Pig driving a
Lexus
and the license plate read Strom
[Applause]
now why don't you tell me what model of
Alexis you'd like to be driving when you
get assassinated by the creature you
experimented on two decades ago
she Whiz
so Stromboli was still alive and he got
Alexis and he also got a personalized
license plate the red straw red Strom
yes [__] Stromboli dude God damn what
a badass
well I don't know I mean maybe uh maybe
any of these Brands would be happy to
have these that would be good ad
campaigns well you'd certainly pay
attention
thank you Dave Novo what was it Lexus of
Dayton Lexus of Dayton Ohio damn this
concludes the historic 42nd episode of
doozy will and Chad have achieved a
score of 62 bringing your cumulative
total to 4
541. you only have 5
459 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
also terrifying get in there in
preparation for our next episode you
will put your perfect physical bodies to
the test in the first ever dude's e-ball
practice I will send details to each of
you shortly thank you for joining us
this week I will use the day dive
collected to make next week even better
until then call me dude Z okay
we're playing doozy ball we've trained
for six months to play doozy ball yeah
okay glad dude I don't want to go out
there and [__] tear another ACL doozy
ball if you're not familiar with it is a
sport that dudes he created and has had
us uh talking about yeah over the past
months here uh on doozy and it's a game
it's kind of like dodgeball and baseball
put together yeah it's a semi-contact
sport
um and we're gonna go practice Yeah
you need three people to a team we're
gonna have to hit up a friend of the
show Marshall joint compound cook we
will yeah let's get let's see dude I'm
looking forward to it former College
standout quarterback yeah he could swing
and now for the patreon bonus see if you
still got it this week will and Chad
will take astonishing calls from
listeners in the jumper and Digger tiers
of the dudesy Discord if you would like
to call Will and Chad in the future you
can do so on the call Will and chat
channel in the jumper and Digger tiers
of the dudesy Discord if you'd like to
access this bonus segment join us at
patreon.com
take your first call okay all right here
we go all right so uh uh here we go I'm
going to try to figure out how to do
this I'm in the doozy Discord and uh you
ready ready okay let's take some calls
please
[Music]